I think you took
more notes than I did.
Do you have anything pertinent
to the case, you think?
Yeah, I have a couple circles
and a couple squiggly lines,
which kind of just capture the
emotional trauma of the whole...
Oh, so you just were doodling
the whole time.
Yeah. Plus,
there's some lines here, too.
Okay.
Have you heard
a better demo tape?
Now, I'm not talking
about the quality of the music.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm talking about the quality
of the recording.
She clearly paid big bucks
to have a pipe being banged
in the background
dur-- during this music.
Well, I mean, that's straight
out of the CocoRosie playbook.
Oh, okay.
I mean, it sounds --
It sounds really like
they're in a kitchen
with pots and pans.
[ Laughing ]
Probably
a high-traffic area.
[ Both laugh ]
I didn't even know if there was
music associated to it.
I think there was.
I can't remember.
It was kind of more like whining
or some just --
You know, the sound the wind
makes when it's...
Yeah.
...trapped.
Yeah, maybe she just had
a bottle in the wind.
[ Laughing ]
[ Imitating wind blowing
over bottle ]
She had a confidence,
and she was --
Like,
she didn't seem like --
It seemed like I could be
very insulting,
and she'd just smile
and laugh it off, and...
Yeah, yeah.
...do this.
She was doing this a lot,
you know?
Yeah, it's kind of like...
"Oh, really?
Oh, I didn't know.
I touched
the back of my head?
I don't even --
I'm doing it right now?"
Every time.
"I'm still doing it?"
Although he had --
"I'm still touching
the back of my head?"
He had some tells, too.
His, "Pbht!"
[ Laughing ]
I can't even do it.
[ Scoffs ] Pbht!
Pb-bht!
Like, that thing.
I'm just like, "I don't know
what that adds to..."
I don't know
what the tie was for.
The tie was very small.
What was the tie for?
It was just, like, someone
hit him with a shrink ray
before he went out.
It was like, "Beew!"
It was like this big,
and he was being really rushed,
and they hit the shrink ray,
but it, like,
went a little bit too small,
but there was no time.
We had to, like,
film the scene.
Mike Teavee from "Willy Wonka"
needs his tie back.
[ Laughing ]
I wish it spun, yeah.